Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du Alter, mir gefällt das hier alles nicht mehr mit dir. Ich verklag dich jetzt.
Tja Tim, da hast du wohl nicht die AGB gelesen, als wir an einem schönen Sonntag
im August 2011 zusammen essen waren.
Logbuch Letzpolitik Nummer 499.
Uiuiui.
Uiuiui. Das heißt, dass heute der 22.
August 2024 ist. Ja. Und was heißt es noch?
Dass in etwas mehr als einer Woche gibt.
Es wieder neue HTTP-Status-Codes.
Gibt es neue HTTP-Status-Codes?
Und,
in etwas mehr als einer Woche, nämlich am 30. August, spielt der Fußballklub
Union Berlin zu Hause gegen... Erster Fußballklub Union Berlin.
So viel Zeit muss sein.
Erster Fußballklub Union Berlin zu Hause gegen den FC St.
Pauli.
Ja, und ich würde ja vorschlagen.
Was würdest du vorschlagen?
Dass wir bei der LMP 500 100 die Shirts des Siegers tragen.
Nee, nix.
Das kann ich dir nicht zumuten, mit einem Unionsshirt da irgendwie rumzusitzen.
Also, ich meine, die Frage ist, ob du deinem Verein vertraust oder nicht.
Was heißt vertrauen?
Das macht mir jetzt nicht so einen eisernen Eindruck, Tim.
Unser Saisonziel heißt Klassenerhalt.
Also, wichtig wäre mir auf jeden Fall, dass du dann bei der LMP 500 noch eine Stimme hast.
Ja, dafür kann ich sorgen. Aber definitiv ist erstmal Fußball angesagt.
Du kannst ja leider nicht kommen und dementsprechend muss ich dich da vertreten.
Ich frohde mich.
Ja, das ist gut.
Hast du ein Ticket?
Ob ich ein Ticket habe oder ein Ticket über habe?
Über.
Na, über müsste ich nochmal schauen. Es war mir eigentlich eins zugesagt worden,
das wurde mir dann kurzfristig wieder entzogen.
Aber in eurem...
Kurzfristig kann sich da immer was ergeben Wir haben da so Kanäle Gucken wir
mal Gucken wir mal Ansonsten sind wir im Endspurt für die 500.
Sendung Noch gibt es ein paar Tickets.
Guck mal hier so eine Mütze Möchtest du so eine Mütze dann aufziehen von St. Pauli?
Ich war bei mehr St. Pauli-Spielen in der letzten Saison als du.
Du bist ja nicht immer so, als ob du so ein großer Fan bist.
Ich will einfach nur mal gerne dich in einem vernünftigen T-Shirt sehen.
Naja, kannst du ja dann. Hab ja schöne neue Union-Trikots gekauft.
Du, das Risiko ist,
für mich ist es keins. Ich habe ein Union-Trainingshemd. Ich kann das problemlos anziehen.
Das ist doch gut, das können wir auch machen.
Aber, du machst hier Chicken.
Ja, ich weiß, was ich gehört. Das kann ich nicht bringen.
Gerade im Angesicht der Niederlage gilt es ja, Solidarität zu zeigen.
Man springt doch nicht einfach auf den Zug irgendeines dahergelaufenen Zufallssieders auf.
Sondern da muss man dann die Größe haben.
Auch im Zeichen des Untergangs muss man immer noch Haltung zeigen.
Deswegen machen wir diese Sendung hier.
Dann drehen wir die Wette um. Wir tragen die T-Shirts des Verlierers.
Traust du dich nämlich auch nicht.
So sieht es nämlich aus. Du warst einfach...
Na wieso? Dann hat es der Verein ja auch verdient, dass ich mitfeiere.
Schwierig, ey.
Dich verklage ich.
Okay, dann...
Dann aber folgendes, keine Trikots. Ich habe keinen Bock, dass du da mit diesen...
Achso, jetzt muss ich mir auch noch richtige Klamotten kaufen für den Abend oder was.
Ordentliche Arbeitskleidung. Na gut, ich sehe schon, wir kommen ja nicht auf grünen Zweig.
Wie möchtest du denn gekleidet sein? Gibt es überhaupt ein Dresscode für die Veranstaltung?
Das hat mein Personal Stylist noch nicht entschieden.
Die handeln da gerade noch die Verträge aus mit den unterschiedlichen Product Placern.
Aber wir sollten uns vielleicht abstimmen. Nicht, dass einer von uns dann underdressed ist.
Wer von uns beiden wäre das wohl?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist schwierig.
Wenn du im St. Pauli-Trikot ankommst, dann hast du schon mal schlechte Karten.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Wir sind schon ein bisschen schicker.
Wir können ja dann mal rumfragen, wie so die Verteilung zwischen Unionheim und St.
Pauli-Fels ist. Das könnte in der Tat ganz spannend sein.
Weil wir haben natürlich den Lokalvorteil, aber es gibt ja dann schon so eine
gewisse Grundsolidarität mit St. Pauli im linken Umfeld.
Gar keine Frage.
Wie gar keine Frage.
Mal gucken, wie die Ergebnisse sind.
Wir machen das in West-Berlin. Du kannst froh sein, wenn da nicht mehr Herr Taner sind.
Das kann überhaupt nicht passieren. Das ist vollkommen unmöglich.
Kommen wir zum Feedback.
Feedback haben wir einiges bekommen. Wie sollte es auch anders sein?
Und wir haben ja wieder alles falsch gemacht.
Haben wir auch.
Erstmal geht es um die Dosen in zweierlei Hinsicht. Ich habe ja die Weißblechdose
beim grünen Klee gelobt und als Errungenschaft gelobt. Und dazu mein Pascal Tim.
Leider habe ich schlechte Nachrichten zu Dosen. Die Kunststoffbeschichtung,
die auf der Innenseite von fast allen Dosen, sowohl Getränke als auch Konservendosen,
vorhanden ist, um zu verhindern, dass der Doseninhalt die metallische Dosenwand korrodieren kann,
enthält in aller Regel Bisphenol A.
BPA wirkt unter anderem als Endokriner Disruptor, was auch immer das heißt.
Endokrin hat was mit Hormonen zu tun.
Ja, wirkt bei Säugetieren inklusive Menschen ähnlich wie das Hormon Östrogen.
Die einzigen Dosen, die ich bisher gesehen habe, die scheinbar keine Kunststoffbeschichtung
enthalten waren, waren Ananasdosen. Hier scheint es auszureichen,
dass Weißblech verzinkt ist und auf der Dose steht drauf, dass man den Inhalt
nach dem Öffnen der Dosen sofort umfüllen soll.
Vermutlich würde die Dose sonst anfangen zu korrodieren, wodurch unerwünschte
Metallionen ins Lebensmittel wandern würden.
Ja gut, also so viel dazu. Also kauft mehr Ananas.
Vielleicht könnte man aus Ananas auch Batterien machen, wenn Ananasionen so
wandeln. Ananas-Ionen-Batterie.
Und was passiert, wenn du jetzt die ganze Zeit Östrogen konsumierst?
Das könnte auch Konsequenzen haben.
Das erklärt den Bierdosen geformten Körper einiger Menschen.
So, dann kommen wir weiter. Machen wir weiter?
Ja.
Du hast ja mehrere Fehler in einem Satz.
Es war alles komplett daneben.
Also erstens, Dosen sind schlecht, außer Ananasdosen.
Genau, gefährlich und es wachsen Dinge dann auf einmal, die nicht wachsen sollten.
Dann sagte Peter noch, Tim liegt leider falsch damit, dass ihm bei In the Can
die Dosen für Nahrungsmittel gemeint sind.
Der Begriff ist aus dem Filmgeschäft. Ein Film war in the can,
wenn die Produktion fertig ist und der physische Film in den Dosen bereit zur
Auslieferung an die Kinos ist.
Ja, also das hätte ich fast auch gewusst. Aber hast du nicht.
Aber dass das irgendwie, dass man jetzt irgendwie einen so schnöden und wenig
glamourösen Vorgang wie Essen in eine Dose machen nicht als Metapher für einen
zufriedenstellenden Abschluss nimmt,
habe ich schon irgendwie so als nagenden Zweifel in meinem Hinterkopf gehabt.
Aber du warst nicht bereit, ihn zu äußern.
Nee, hätte ich mal. Dann hättest du heute ein St. Pauli-Shirt an.
Da bin ich gerade nochmal davon gekommen.
Naja, aber es ist nicht meine einzige Unterlassung.
So, dann gab es relativ viel Feedback zu der Diskussion, zu der kurzen Diskussion
rund um die, wie heißt das gleich?
Monopolstellung von Google.
Ja, also genau, beziehungsweise dem Antitrust-Urteil des amerikanischen,
US-amerikanischen Bundesgerichts und ja, dazu gab es viel Text,
den lese ich jetzt mal vor.
Ich würde zuvor erst mal sagen, weil mir das wirklich nach dieser Sendung,
ich hatte dir das ja auch geschrieben, einfach mal, wollte ich zu Beginn sagen, einfach mal zurecht.
Da haben wir zurecht viel Feedback für bekommen, weil wir in der letzten Sendung,
insbesondere ich auch, einfach nicht so richtig fit bei der Sache waren und
das Thema haben wir einfach scheiße behandelt.
Das haben wir auch in den Kommentaren klar gesagt bekommen. Wir versuchen es heute nochmal.
Nicht, dass wir besser vorbereitet sind.
Nein, aber deswegen auch heute mal ein längerer Feedback-Blog.
Genau. Philipp schreibt also,
hey, die Google-Monopol-Diskussion war leider unvollständig und bezieht sich
auf einen Heiser-Artikel und zitiert daraus,
denn das Gericht weist aufdrücklich darauf hin, dass der Konzern nicht bloß
seine Marktmacht missbraucht hat,
um seinen US-Marktanteil auf rund 95% auszubauen und abzusichern,
sondern auch um überhöhte Preise für Textwerbung rund um Suchergebnisse zu verrechnen.
Die berühmte Monopolrente.
Weiteres Zitat. Dabei hat Google festgestellt, dass es keine nennenswerten Umsatzverluste
erleiden werde, selbst wenn es die Qualität der Suchmaschine deutlich reduziere.
Ja.
Und vor allem aber habe Google die Parameter für seine Preise ohne Rücksichtnahme
auf Mitbewerber gesetzt.
Beispielsweise können Google die Preise über dem eigentlichen Auktionsergebnis
ansetzen, was in einem vom Wettbewerb geprägten Markt unmöglich wäre.
Und zu guter Letzt, Werbetreibende erhalten weniger Informationen und sie können
sich nicht mehr dagegen wehren, dass bestimmte Suchbegriffe automatisch ihre
Werbeabschaltung auslösen.
Das führt zu weniger genau zugeschnittenen Werbekampagnen bei gleichzeitig erhöhten
Preisen. Ja, alles richtig.
Also es ging sozusagen noch um sehr viel mehr als das, was wir jetzt unmittelbar behandelt haben.
Ich hatte mich halt da konkret auf diese Fragestellungen konzentriert mit der
Default-Einstellung der Suchmaschine.
Also dieses Urteil ist relativ umfangreich und es wird Google so einiges vorgeworfen,
trotz alledem wissen wir eben noch nicht, was die Konsequenz daraus ist.
Es gibt dann eben diese Feststellung, das haben wir festgestellt und was dann
tatsächlich auferlegt wird, das kommt dann nochmal sehr viel später.
Aber das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, wenn du erkennst, dass du deine,
also das ist wirklich quasi sehr schlecht, dass Google das selber festgestellt
hat, wenn du sagst, wir können unsere Dienstleistung hier sogar in der Qualität
verringern, ohne Umsatzverluste zu machen.
Das ist ja die Definition von Marktmacht.
Beziehungsweise Missbrauch dessen.
Oder Missbrauch. Und bei Heise im Artikel geht der Satz auch noch weiter.
Und wie geneigte Leser wissen, hat sich dieses Studienergebnis inzwischen bewahrheitet.
Dass sie nämlich quasi sich auf dieser marktbeherrschenden Stellung ausruhen
können und sich aus dem Wettbewerb nehmen.
Und das ist immer, also du musst immer, und ich weiß, dass das für dich…,
Also auch bei den Apple-Sachen und bei den Google-Sachen, du hast ja immer so
ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, den Nachteil einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung
als solche anzuerkennen.
Was? Wieso? Ich habe da überhaupt kein gutes Haar an Google zu lassen.
Das ist alles nicht okay. Okay, man ist ja vollkommen klar, dass sie diese Macht haben.
Die Frage, die wir diskutiert haben oder die ich aufgebracht habe,
war ja ausschließlich dieses, was hat das jetzt für Auswirkungen auf die Situation
der anderen Marktteilnehmer, ohne dass ich das groß bewerte.
Okay, und da kommen wir aber glaube ich ja mit den anderen Kommentaren auch zu.
Denke ich auch. Dann schrieb nämlich Nick noch zu dem Themenkomplex Hallo zusammen.
Ich möchte noch die Kommentare zu Google und Co. ergänzen. In eurer Diskussion
geht ihr leider am Thema vorbei.
Es ist das ureigene Interesse eines gewinnorientierten, öffentlich gehandelten
Unternehmens, A, den eigenen Marktanteil zu vergrößern, Verdrängung und B,
den Markteintritt für neue Herausforderer zu erschweren.
Das Ziel des Kartellrechts ist es nicht, Monopole oder Oligopole zu verhindern,
sondern wettbewerbsbeschränkende Maßnahmen.
Daher ist es zum Beispiel in Deutschland auch maßgeblich im Gesetz gegen Wettbewerbsbeschränkungen
geregelt, das auch die Ausschreibungspflicht der öffentlichen Hand regelt.
Wenn man die Praktik und das Urteil aus dieser Perspektive betrachtet,
ergibt sich ein völlig anderes Bild. Google kann durch seine Marktmacht absurde
Summen aufbringen, die andere Anbieter niemals mobilisieren könnten.
Damit verhindert Google effektiv, dass andere Suchmaschinen einen relevanten
Marktanteil erreichen und wirtschaftlich arbeiten können.
Das war ja so ein Punkt, dass sie da eben sehr viel Geld zahlen derzeit.
Und ich hatte ja auch gesagt, so könnten ja auch andere zahlen,
haben ja auch andere Kinder viel Geld.
Das ist genau nicht der Fall.
Ja, das kann man so sehen.
Du kannst, also die Frage ist ja, ich glaube das war in einem weiteren Kommentar,
aber den könnten wir vielleicht an der Stelle noch kurz anbringen,
hier von Dilara, kurzer Kommentar, zum Punkt, was Microsoft denn davon abhalten
würde, so eine Summe an Apple zu zahlen, da sie die ja eh hätten.
Während des Gerichtsverfahrens sagte Apples Senior Vice President of Services,
Eddie Cue, there is no prize that Microsoft could ever offer,
um die Default-Suchmaschine zu sein.
Also, klar, Apple sagt, wir wollen, also Apple hat ja so, Apple zieht quasi
selber den größten, finanzschwersten Konkurrenten aus dem Spiel und sagt, übrigens Google,
Wir wollen diese Millionen haben, aber einen Konkurrenten habt ihr schon mal
nicht, das ist Microsoft, ihr müsst euch überhaupt keine Sorgen machen.
Trotzdem zahlt Google ja diese Summe.
Also irgendjemanden wollen die sich ja vom Leib halten.
Und wenn wir sagen, Microsoft kann an diesem Wettbewerb gar nicht teilnehmen,
um wer 20 Milliarden an Apple zahlt, dann schafft Google ja wirklich nur für
alle anderen einfach eine absolut unerträgliche Markteintrittsbarriere.
Und das ist das Problem der Marktbeherrschungsstellung.
Wenn du dein Monopol so stark hast, dass du sagst, ich schmeiß hier alle anderen
raus. Sorry, das wollte ich ganz kurz.
Ja, ich meine, es ist völlig in Ordnung.
Ich frage mich bloß wirklich, was das eigentlich genau aussagt.
Weil, wenn Sie sagen, kein Preis, den Microsoft zahlen, den Sie anbieten könnten.
Gut, da steckt so ein bisschen drin, was Sie auch vielleicht erwarten,
was Sie maximal anbieten könnten. Nein, der meint, Microsoft könnte ja beliebig
viel anbieten. Sagen wir mal, Microsoft würde das Doppelte anbieten.
Dann würde Apple im Zweifelsfall sagen, nein. Ja, aber warum?
Die Frage ist ja, pass auf.
Weil sie ja sozusagen trotzdem sich gezwungen sehen, den Leuten quasi Google zu bieten als Default.
Dann, genau. Und warum zahlt Google dann dieses Geld?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Was ist das Druckmittel? Niemand anders da reinkommen kann.
Es gibt ja einen Preis.
Irgendjemand sitzt bei Google und sagt, es ist uns das wert,
Apple dieses Geld zu geben.
Also irgendjemand sagt ja, hier Sparkasse 20 Milliarden an Apple. Ja?
Und die Person macht das ja mit, die kriegt ja einen Gegenwert dafür.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist denn dieser Gegenwert, wenn du eh die beste
Suchmaschine bist und eigentlich davon ausgehen müsstest, dass Apple,
ähm, den dich sowieso setzen würde,
weil die ganzen Apple-Kunden sagen würden, ey, mein iPhone ist kaputt,
wenn der auf einmal alles irgendwie an, was weiß ich, Bing ginge oder DuckDuckGo
oder hast du nicht gesehen.
Und wieso kriegt jemand bei Google 20 Milliarden aufs Konto und sagt, gib dir mal Apple?
Was ist der Gegenwert? Und der Gegenwert ist, sorg mal dafür,
dass keine Sau überhaupt jemals auf die Idee kommt, mit uns zu konkurrieren.
Es ist nicht, dass da irgendwelche bei Apple saßen und dann saß da der Microsoft-Typ
und sagte, na okay, 19,5 und dann sagte der Google-Typ, na okay,
20 kommen, sag zu, fertig, machen wir und Apple hat gesagt, katsching.
Das ist der Marktartikel. Aber ich will ganz kurz, jetzt habe ich was falsch
gemacht, lass uns vielleicht noch erst Nick das Wort geben, ich habe ja einfach
den Kommentar unterbrochen.
Ja, ja, also ich eier jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen rum,
weil ich wirklich keine wirklich klare Antwort darauf habe oder sagen wir mal
kein wirkliches Verständnis davon habe,
was genau hier eigentlich beide Parteien voneinander zu haben meinen.
Es ist sicherlich nicht nur das Geld. Es ist auch das Geld.
Und in dem Moment, es geht ja auch nicht nur um diese Dienstleistung,
du bist die Default-Suchmaschine.
Weil wenn man jetzt Apples eigenen Worten folgt, dann könnte man ja auch sagen,
Google ist eh das Beste, eure Kunden erwarten, dass Google der Default ist,
sonst denken die, das Telefon ist kaputt, wir brauchen euch gar kein Geld zu zahlen.
Zack, so. Andererseits hat das natürlich trotzdem einen Wert für Google.
Weil es den Markteintritt für neue Herausforderer erschwert.
Das ist genau der Punkt B von Nick.
Aus Apples Perspektive, also warum sollte, also wie gelingt es Apple,
Google Geld dafür abzunehmen?
Ja, genau, das meine ich. Google sieht den Wert darin, sich für 20 Milliarden
Konkurrenz vom Leib zu halten.
Google weiß einfach, pass auf, so schnell kann bei Apple keiner sagen,
lass mal hier meine geile Suchmaschine reintun. Beispiel.
Beispiel.
Perplexity.
Könnte man sagen, was die Qualität angeht, ist sie heute schon besser als Google.
Es ist einfach die bessere Suchmaschine. Google hat genau das gemacht.
Die haben sich ausgeruht. Die haben ihre Suchmaschine nicht mehr weitergebracht.
Da haben wir auch schon vor Jahren drüber gesprochen, wo ich gesagt habe,
von Google kommt keine Innovation.
Da warst du überzeugt, dass von Google Innovation kommt. War ich überzeugt, dass es nicht so ist.
Jetzt gibt es halt irgendwie so Perplexity oder Chat-GPT oder sonst was.
Wenn die sagen würden, hey, weißt du, was voll geil wäre?
Wenn wir die Default-Suchmaschine auf dem iPhone wären.
Das wäre geil. Und dann gibt es aber bei Apple 20 Milliarden in der Tasche, die sagen,
vielleicht nicht, vielleicht lassen wir einfach Google, vielleicht ist das in
Ordnung, dass wir noch zwei, drei Jahre Google dabei halten und Perplexity genau
nicht die Marktanteile kriegen kann.
Wie passt das zu der Aussage von Apple, dass es ja auch dann Microsoft zum Beispiel
keine Chance für Bing geben würde?
Und das ist das, wo ich wirklich frage, das ist...
Das passt alles zusammen und das ist genau der Grund, warum ich mir nicht ganz
sicher bin, ob du das verstehst.
Ja, ich bin mir auch nicht ganz so sicher, ob ich das verstehe,
weil ich verstehe es halt nicht.
Die Zahlung von Google ist primär dafür, dass niemand anderes an der Stelle konkurrieren kann.
Ende des Liedes.
Ja, aber wie passt das zu der Aussage mit, there is no price Microsoft could
ever offer, wenn Microsoft einen höheren Preis liefern würde und es nur das Geld wäre, allein?
Es geht nicht um Microsoft. Das ist ja genau der Punkt, dass es nicht um Microsoft
geht. Weil Microsoft hätte ja die 20 Milliarden.
Perplexity hat sie nicht. Die, die Innovation bringen. Bing ist nun mal keine
Konkurrenz, aber Innovation ist etwas Neues, etwas Besseres.
Ja, aber Google muss ja keine 20 Milliarden zahlen, um Perplexity auszustechen.
Doch! Damit ist gar keiner erst versucht.
Naja okay, das ist aber sehr hoch gepokert.
Die 20 Milliarden, darf ich ganz kurz, die 20 Milliarden drücken den Kaufpreis
von Perplexity, wenn Google erkennt, oh scheiße, da hat es in der Zeit,
während wir Geld gezählt haben, hat jemand was geileres gebaut,
den müssen wir jetzt kaufen.
Und dann sagt Perplexity, wir sind ja viel besser als ihr, wir kosten so und
so viel Milliarden und sagt Google,
pass mal auf mein Freund, ihr seid doch weit davon entfernt,
irgendwelche Marktanteile zu bekommen, weil wir 20 Milliarden schon an Apple
gegeben haben, damit ihr die nicht kriegt.
Ich würde sagen, euer Preis ist sehr viel geringer und dann sagt Perplexity,
hast du recht, wir müssen erstmal 20 Milliarden funden, um euch da zu matchen
und dann sagt Google, weißt du was, wir haben 25.
Es geht darum, diese Services werden bewertet in Marktanteil und wenn Google
einfach Marktanteile mit Geldbarrieren zumacht,
Das ist das. Und das ist das Ende des Lieds. Aber vielleicht sollen wir wirklich
nix Kommentar nochmal zu Ende legen.
Naja, das Ganze geht so ein bisschen davon aus, dass man jetzt vielleicht das
einfach verbieten kann und dann würde gar kein Geld mehr bezahlt werden an Apple.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das passieren wird, weil hier ist schon auch noch ein
gegenseitiger Deal am Start.
Aber der ist nicht 20 Milliarden wert, das weiß doch jedes Kind.
Das wissen Leute, die noch nicht, also die meisten Leute können nicht bis 20 Milliarden zählen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wenn es dann nicht das wert wäre, dass das dann trotzdem
gezahlt wird. Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann es nicht beurteilen. Vielleicht weiß es Nick, weiß ich nicht.
Jetzt haben wir seinen Kommentar so ein bisschen gespalten. Ja,
du hast versucht es zu unterbrechen, ist ja auch gelungen.
Also es geht bei ihm ja um die Perspektive, was jetzt dieser Rechtsbereich versucht zu gestalten.
In der Natur dieses Rechtsbereichs, schreibt er weiter, liegt es aber selten,
dass dem Monopolisten eine Handlung vollständig untersagt wird.
Meistens wird nur auf eine Verbesserung der Wettbewerbssituation hingearbeitet.
Es ist also davon auszugehen, Achtung Glaskugel, dass Google in dem Marktanteil
der Browser oder Plattform beschränkt wird und sich an den durchschnittlichen
Preis der sonstigen Transaktionen halten werden muss.
Außerdem wird das in der Regel nur so lange Anwendung finden,
wie Google weiter eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hat.
So eine weitere Perspektive hat
noch Significant Otter. Das gibt übrigens Bonuspunkte für den Nickname.
Hatten wir glaube ich schon.
Ja, habe ich auch schon Bonuspunkte verteilt.
Weiß ich nicht. Kann man nicht genug vergeben.
Significant Otter schreibt, das Kerngeschäft von Alphabet slash Google ist Werbung.
Nicht nur durch die Suche, sondern auch allgemein durch die über Google AdWords
geschaltete Werbung auf anderen Seiten. Und indirekt deshalb Tracking,
da Google massiv auf trackende Werbung setzt.
Eine zentrale Strategie von Google ist es jetzt, den Werbemarkt so zu gestalten,
dass die eigenen Gewinne maximiert und damit das Nutzen-Kosten-Verhältnis für.
Werbeschaltende gerade noch so hoch ist, dass sie die Dienste nutzen.
Das gelingt ihnen aber vor allem deshalb, weil Google selbst in diesem Markt
in allen denkbaren Rollen auftritt.
Auf der Business-Seite sind das die Rollen werbeanzeigender Partner,
zum Beispiel Search und YouTube und werbeschaltender Partner quasi alle Konsumerprodukte
von Google und auf der technischen Seite die Rollen Betriebssystem,
Android, Webbrowser, Chrome,
Webhosting-Anbieter, Google Cloud, DNS-Server und so weiter.
Dadurch hat Google die einzigartige Möglichkeit, den Markt und die Technologie
des Internets auf allen Ebenen mitzugestalten und zu versuchen,
ihn für das eigene Geschäftsmodell zu optimieren.
Beispiele dafür sind die zentrale Tracking-API unter Android,
die Googles applikationsübergreifendes Tracking auch außerhalb von Webseiten ermöglicht.
Oder jüngst die Beschreibung, Third-Party-Cookies in Chrome technisch zu verhindern
und das Tracking stattdessen direkt vom Google-kontrollierten Browser stattfinden zu lassen.
Es gibt, soweit ich weiß, auch Hinweise, wenn nicht sogar Beweise,
dass Google die Doppelrolle im Realtime-Bidding beim Schalten von Werbung,
also Werbe-Netzwerk und werbeschaltende Partei zu sein,
ausnutzt, um die Gebote von anderen Werbeschaltenden durch geschicktes Bieten zu optimieren.
Ich erinnere mich da an einen Vortrag vor ein paar Jahren auf einem CCC-Event,
aber ich finde ihn gerade nicht wieder.
Das ist in meinen Augen die gefährlichste Spielart von Googles Monopolstellung.
Also gar keine Frage. Google ist einfach in diesen ganzen Werbemarkt so massiv
eingerückt und haben sich an allen Stellen platziert.
Am Anfang, am Ende, in den Mechanismen dazwischen haben große Adnetworks aufgekauft
und aufgebaut und machen das ganze Realtime-Bidding.
Die haben schon sehr viel Kontrolle darüber.
Ich bin einfach sehr gespannt, was jetzt das Bundesgericht sich an Sanktionen
einfallen lassen wird und vor allem, ob die funktionieren.
Weil das ist immer so eine Sache Wenn die Großen sich boxen Wer da Am Ende siegreich davon zieht.
Was ich ja Sehr spannend finde Also du sagst ja selber hier Die,
Dieses Verhältnis zwischen Apple und Google, wer das iPhone gut ohne Google
Suchleiste, wer Google gut ohne iPhone Kunden und so weiter.
Ähnliches Verhältnis haben ja auch Meta und die Deutsche Telekom.
Du erinnerst dich an den Streit, den wir vor einigen Wochen hatten.
Also die hatten. hatten, ja, beziehungsweise die haben den Streit ja schon sehr lange.
Und zwar geht es dabei darum, auch das wurde in den Kommentaren nochmal sehr
gut erläutert, die Deutsche Telekom bietet im Prinzip Zugang in ihr Netz zu
über unüblich überhöhten Preisen an Facebook an.
Das ist, das kann man glaube ich, das ist glaube ich faktisch,
soweit haben wir es auseinander,
klamüsert, üblicherweise würdest du irgendwo dich mit dem Internet verbinden,
und dann kommst du auch an die Kunden der Deutschen Telekom und für Facebook
sagt die Deutsche Telekom, naja, okay, pass auf, von euch kommt so viel,
also Instagram und so weiter, kommt so viel,
dafür machen wir extra Peering-Punkte, auch richtig,
aber an diesen Peering-Punkten rechnen wir nicht nach Peering ab,
sondern nach Transit, das heißt, der ganze Müll und die ganzen Instagram-Bilder,
die ihr in unser Netz ballert, da müsst ihr nochmal mehr für zahlen als andere.
Und das hat Facebook eine lange Zeit mitgemacht, dann haben sie gesagt,
nee, jetzt machen wir es nicht mehr,
dann hat die Deutsche Telekom die Leitungen, hat die Leitungen aber weiter genutzt, hat gesagt,
wir zahlen nicht mehr und dann wurden sie jetzt dazu verurteilt,
dass sie die Leistung, die sie da in Anspruch genommen haben aus alten Verträgen
der Deutschen Telekom, dass sie die bezahlen müssen.
Und jetzt müssen die beiden ja eigentlich gerade da sitzen und sich eine neue
Lösung einfallen lassen.
Also sicherlich ist ja Meta unzufrieden mit dem Urteil.
Also werden die jetzt da gerade irgendwie sitzen. Und ich stelle mir so vor,
wie diese Diskussionen laufen.
Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, also beide rasen ja auf den Abgrund zu.
Das ist ja genau dieses, sie haben ja ein gleiches Interesse.
Der Zustand jetzt gerade ist der, der für beide in ihrem Interesse ist.
Bist du Deutsche Telekom, kannst du Instagram nutzen.
Facebook ist gut in Deutschland vertreten, alle beide sollten eigentlich happy sein,
entscheiden sich aber jetzt auf so einen Abgrund zuzurasen, in dem Facebook
halt sagt, pass auf, ich zahle einfach nicht mehr dafür, dass deine Kunden das kriegen,
was sie im Internet wollen.
Uns ist teuer genug, Deutschland zu bedienen.
Und die Deutsche Telekom sagt,
wäre doch total schade, wenn ihr da jetzt irgendwie langsamer durchkommt.
Und dann musst du dir überlegen, dann müsst ihr aber Facebook sagen.
Ja, das ist total schade.
Oder?
Das wäre total schade, wenn eure Kunden auf einmal kein Facebook mehr haben.
Also beide können ja eigentlich auch nicht einander drohen.
Also beide stehen da im Prinzip mit so einem Messer und sagen,
das wäre doch wirklich schade, wenn wir das in den Bauch rauchen.
Weißt du, wie der Film heißt, den wir jetzt zitieren müssen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Film heißt, den wir jetzt zitieren müssen.
Naja, zwei Autos rasen an den Abgrund der Schlucht zu.
Wie heißt der mit Michael Dean?
Denn sie wissen nicht.
Was sie tun. Stimmt, ich hatte den englischen Titel. Wie ist der englische Titel?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ganz anders.
Unter Garantie.
Rebel without a cause.
Das kann sein, ja.
Und die brettern jetzt beide dazu und ich stelle mir gerade vor,
wie die da so sitzen und der eine sagt, ey pass auf, ich dreh das jetzt ab,
ja, und dann sagt die und der andere sagt,
ey bist du verrückt dann haben deine Nutzer halt kein Facebook mehr oder,
ey ich dreh das jetzt ab und dann sagt die TK, ey bist du verrückt,
dann fehlt dir halb Deutschland,
und einer von beiden geht jetzt hin und sagt,
ja ja, ist so, machen wir jetzt mal gucken und das spannende ist,
wer von beiden Ja, weil es ist für beide, wäre es absoluter Irrsinn,
Also eigentlich müssen die sich einigen,
Und wenn sie es jetzt, angenommen, die täten das nicht, dann,
was würde dann passieren?
Und vor allem, wer von beiden, da könnten wir auch nochmal wetten.
Da musst du ein T-Shirt von tragen.
Telekom oder Meta?
Ich bin doch nicht deine persönliche Werbebande.
Naja, also wenn du ein Telekom-Shirt tragen müsstest, wüsste ich eins.
Die sind Trikotspanns, bei deinen Freunden aus München, oder?
Ich habe früher mal meine eigenen Telekom-T-Shirts produziert im CCC.
Die waren sehr schön. Kennst du die noch?
Irgendwas verändertes, ne? Telegnom?
Naja, die bezogen sich auf diese damalige Charme-Kampagne der Telekom,
als sie privatisiert wurden.
Wo sie dann mit ihren tanzenden Buchstaben so Deutschland und dann war das T,
nämlich jeweiligen Wort, war immer so ein Telekom-T.
Und dann war immer alles ganz toll und dann haben wir halt so null Tarif kaputt
und solche Dinger gemacht, haben sie uns natürlich auch gleich verklagt.
Echt?
Ja.
Und dann habt ihr auch Gipfeltreffen.
Ich hab gefragt, ob sie die AGB-Relesen haben. Ja, nee, mussten wir dann erstmal
einstellen, aber die Shirts waren gut.
Ich fand's auf jeden Fall jetzt ganz, ich fand's jetzt auf jeden Fall ganz,
Also dieses Gedankenspiel ganz lustig und was passiert?
Einer von beiden sagt, mach doch. Einer blinzelt nicht.
Und dann ist aber die nächste Frage, also lange werden sie den Zustand nicht
aufrechterhalten können. Ja, also wenn die Telekom-Leute kein Facebook mehr
haben, dann bin ich mal gespannt, was Markentreue bedeutet.
Ob jetzt die Leute sagen, ich bleib bei der Deutschen Telekom,
ob die Sonderkündigungsrechte in Anspruch nehmen oder ob die sagen,
oh krass, mir geht's auf einmal viel besser, meine Magersucht ist weg und ich
muss mir auch nicht mehr andauernd die Lippen aufspritzen, ist gar nicht so
schlecht eigentlich so ohne Facebook. Also es wäre eigentlich sein guter Tag.
Aber dann würde die PR-Schlacht der beiden Giganten losgehen,
wo dann Facebook sagen muss, oder die Deutsche Telekom sagen muss,
ich will einfach mehr Geld von Facebook.
Und das, also, faszinierend.
Ich würde ja eigentlich schätzen, die werden sich einigen.
Aber wenn sie sich nicht einigen, dann würde ich, boah, da bräuchten wir echt,
da müssten wir in die strategischen Popcornreserven.
Also irgendjemand wird sich auf jeden Fall beklagen am Schluss. Ich bin gespannt.
Aber wer weiß, ob das überhaupt passiert. Vielleicht einigen die sich auch und dann ist gut.
Ich bin mir sicher, die lesen gerade wie verrückt die gegenseitigen AGBs.
Ja, AGBs lesen ist eine gute Idee, Leute. Das ist nämlich sozusagen jetzt die große Gefahr.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du die Story mitbekommen hast, ich habe das auch nur
so am Rande mitgemacht, da gab es auf jeden Fall jetzt neue Bewegungen.
Schon im Oktober 23 begab es sich, dass ein Irrpaar in so eine Disney World,
in Orlando, so ein Resort.
Ja, Disney World Orlando.
Das macht man ja so in den USA. Dann geht man so zu Disney World, das gehört da so auch.
Das ist ein Ding.
Das gehört dazu.
It's a thing.
Ja, also man muss das auch gemacht haben. So ein bisschen so wie die Muslime müssen so...
Nach Mekka? Und die haben jetzt bis nach Orlando. Oder Anaheim.
In Anaheim ist Disneyland.
Ja, Worldland, was auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Oder Paris. Die fliegen ja auch nach Paris, um da in Disney World zu gehen.
Da sparen die mal richtig.
Frankreich. Okay. Anyway, auf jeden Fall war das alles ganz dramatisch und ganz furchtbar,
weil sie sind ja da hingegangen, weil die Frau hatte Allergien und sind dann
extra in diesen Raglan Road Irish Pub gegangen,
weil sie generell auch irgendwie davon ausgegangen sind, dass bei Disney,
weil sie damit auch immer geworben haben, besonders vorsichtig sind,
was so die Zutaten und so weiter betrifft.
Und entsprechende Inkompatibilitäten mit Nahrungsmitteln.
Und da wurden auch die Mitarbeiter nochmal darauf hingewiesen.
Trotzdem wurden aber am Ende Gerichte gebracht, die wohl Nüsse und Milch enthielten,
wo sie leider allergisch gegen war.
Und das führte dann dazu, dass sie einen anaphylaktischen Schock erlitt und verstarb.
So weit, so furchtbar. in der Folge hat dann der Witwer Klage erhoben gegen Disney,
wegen weiß ich nicht genau was da drin stand wahrscheinlich wegen ich weiß nicht
genau worauf ich könnte mir vorstellen,
am Ende geht es ja immer um Geld ist ja auch nachvollziehbar weil sie sind ja
nun extra dahin gegangen und trotz aller Beteuerung haben sie dann und auch
aller Warnung haben sie dann sozusagen sozusagen, sich nicht korrekt verhalten.
Das ist natürlich in den USA mal ein großes Ding, solche Konsumenten klagen.
Und dann kamen irgendwie Disneys Anwälte und meinten so, du kannst ja gar nicht klagen.
Weil du hast ja vor vier Jahren mal ein Disney-Plus-Probe-Abo abgeschlossen und in den AGBs stand,
ja nee, du darfst uns gar nicht verklagen, du musst ein Schiedsgericht anrufen,
wenn du in irgendeiner Form Issues hast hier mit unserem Dienst.
Und wenn du halt einmal in die Disney-Tür reingegangen bist,
egal welche, stand übrigens auch auf deinem Ticket, was du irgendwie am Eingang
gekauft hast, um in diesen Disney-Resort reinzumarschieren, dann steht dir der Klageweg nicht offen.
Geil. Was ist das Geschmacklos? Lawyer Logic ist ihnen natürlich dann um die
Ohren gefangen. Das ist wenig überraschend.
Und der Aufschrei hat jetzt wohl auch dazu geführt, dass sie da zurückrudern.
Offensichtlich hat mal jemand die Tabellenkalkulation aufgemacht und die potenziellen
Verklagungskosten und deren Folgen verglichen mit dem öffentlichen Schaden,
den sie jetzt gerade anrichten.
Und jetzt wurde dieser Antrag zurückgezogen.
Aber warum erwähnen wir das hier?
Das ist halt so ein Trend, dass man in zunehmendem Maße einerseits erstmal eine
ganze Menge in so AGBs ablastet.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt neu, das gibt es ja schon immer.
AGBs können auch gut sein, also gerade so für Leute, die Dienste anbieten,
die werden natürlich auch auf jeden möglichen Scheiß hin verklagt oft und es
ist sicherlich kein Fehler sowas zu haben.
Also auch übrigens mal nur so als Tipp, wenn ihr also wirklich auch als Selbstständige
in einem Dienstleistungsverhältnis zu anderen Unternehmen steht,
dann ist das wirklich gar keine schlechte Idee,
so ein paar Dinge, da sollte man sich mal in Ruhe mit dem Anwalt zusammensetzen,
in so einer AGB zusammenzupacken und zu sagen, wenn ihr mich beauftragt,
dann sind das meine allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich euren Ehepartner vergifte, dürfte...
Nee, so im Sinne von Rechnungen müssen bezahlt werden.
Wenn sie nicht bezahlt werden, dann passiert das automatisch und ihre willigt ein.
Dann vergiften wir den Ehepartner. Genau, also ich sage nur,
AGBs sind nicht generell schlimm.
Nur wir haben es halt jetzt so, dass eben große Konzerne, die international
operieren, die in ihrer Konzernstruktur alle möglichen Subunternehmungen haben,
jetzt auf einmal anfangen, generell so eine rechtliche Zwangsjacke allen überzustülpen,
unter dem Vorwand, sondern unter diesem Deckmantel des,
ja hier haben wir was total interessantes für euch hier.
Disney-Filme und ihr müsst jetzt Pixar gucken und so weiter.
Das wollt ihr doch bestimmt machen.
Und damit sozusagen Sachen zu akzeptieren, die dann am Ende auf einmal für irgendetwas
Geld was für dieses Angebot nicht sind.
Also es kann ja auch Also.
Musst du halt auch erstmal gegen ihn vorgehen. Und ich meine,
es wird nicht immer so extrem sein, wie die Frau ist gestorben,
sondern es sind dann halt andere Dinge und es ist definitiv ein Problem.
Also ich würde grundsätzlich erstmal davon ausgehen, dass niemand sagen kann,
Teil meiner AGBs ist, dass du keine rechtlichen Schritte gegen mich einleiten darfst.
Das wäre mir neu, wenn eine solche Klausel durchsetzbar ist.
Aber okay, Mickey Maus ist ein Arschloch.
Mickey Maus ist ein Arschloch.
Vielleicht war es ja auch Dagobert Duck.
Stimmt, da war der Dagobert Duck aber im ganz großen Ruder.
Wir haben übrigens Im Prinzip muss man sagen Fortnite gibt es wieder auf dem iPhone Und alle so, yeah.
Das ist ja wirklich Eine Saga Also soll kommen,
Ne, gibt es auch jetzt schon Ich habe gelesen, den gibt es jetzt Also ich mache
sowas ja nicht Aber du kannst dir den Epic Games Store Auf deinem iPhone bestellen
Und damit müssen wir eine Geschichte zu Ende,
erzählen, denn vor ungefähr vier Jahren ist Fortnite aus dem App Store geflogen. Das Spiel von Epic.
Und das ist ein Battle Royale Spiel, wurde mir glaube ich damals erklärt. Ja.
Und Epic hatte versucht damals quasi Verträge Ecke für dieses Fortnite in irgendeiner
Weise herzustellen, die nicht von Apples Revenue-Share betroffen sind.
Daraufhin hat der Apple die runtergeworfen und jetzt waren die vier Jahre,
gab es das einfach nicht. Und dann...
Kam der Digital Markets Act, der Apple jetzt gezwungen hat, alternative App-Stores
zuzulassen, in denen andere Leute andere Regeln gelten lassen können.
Und das hat Epic jetzt getan.
Nur vier Jahre später hat also jetzt Epic einen App-Store auf dem iPhone und
kann da sein Fortnite verkaufen.
Und sie zahlen aber quasi jetzt für den App-Store die Gebühr an Apple.
Also irgendwie glaube ich so wirklich, besonders vorteilhaft für die ist es jetzt nicht, oder?
Das müssen die selber entscheiden, ob das für sie vorteilhaft ist.
Also sie haben auf jeden Fall, also das läuft ja so, wir hatten das ja schon
mal ausführlich gesprochen, dass du jetzt erstmal diese App selber installieren
musst und für diese Präsenz müssen sie zahlen.
Und das kritisiert auch der Epic-Chef Tim Sweeney, der sagt,
naja, die User brauchen jetzt 15 Schritte, um den App Store auf ihren Geräten zu installieren.
Oder es kann auch sein, dass das, also ich weiß nicht, 15 Schritte,
vielleicht auch für den App Store.
Natürlich Apple wird das, bin mir sicher, dass Apple sich da um eine absolut
nahtlose User Experience bemüht hat, wenn man auf einmal alternative App-Stores
auf dieses Gerät kriegt.
Sie zahlen das, ich bin mal gespannt.
Epic kritisiert, klar, so wie ihr diesen App Store jetzt gerade für uns bepreist,
lohnt es sich eigentlich für niemanden da hinzugehen, das ist natürlich auch wieder Apples Ziel,
man wird jetzt sehen, ob Apples Umsetzung der DMA-Regeln in Ordnung ist oder nicht.
Ähm, also immerhin, Fortnite auf dem iPhone, bin sehr gespannt,
werde ich weiterhin nicht runterladen, weil ich einfach keine Zeit für sowas,
aber immerhin wird hier eine vier Jahre alte Geschichte zu Ende erzählt.
Ebenfalls zu Ende erzählt wird eine noch viele Jahre ältere Geschichte, nämlich die um Kim.com.
Wir erinnern uns, also Kim.com, eigentlich in Deutschland verurteilter Anlagebetrüger
oder Insiderhandel und was der da alles gemacht hat.
Früher bekannt unter seinem normalen Namen, Kim Schmitz.
Und dann Kimble.
Und vor allem Kimble, das war so sein Hacker- Nick.
Kimble finde ich auch besser als Kim.com.
Ja, das hat er dann Aber auch schon Kimbell war scheiße.
Der hat als Kimbell schon so viel Unheil angerichtet,
der hat ja dann Deutschland auch mehr oder weniger fluchtartig verlassen und
ist über so verschiedene Stationen dann in Neuseeland gelandet,
nachdem er sich auch in Asien nochmal schlecht benommen hat und rausgeworfen wurde.
Also wohin der Typ kommt, der lässt nur verbrannte Erde zurück und ist halt
so ein Aufschneider-Typ, so ein mega Angeber,
also wirklich mit nix und hat eigentlich immer nur andere Leute abgezogen und
dann hat er sich halt irgendwie ganz fett in Kim.com umbenannt und ist halt
so, weiß nicht, so ein Möchtegern-Tramp.
Ja, .com ist ja auch jetzt mehrfach schon durch. Naja, jedenfalls hat der ja Du.
Könntest dich ja auch linus.org oder so benennen.
Gibt's nicht mehr. Ich hab lns.wtf.
Einfach so als Name. Linus Punkt,
Linus Punkt Komma Strich.
Ich kauf mir einfach die TLD.
Punkt Linus.
Ich bin Punkt Linus.
Genau, .com. .tim und .linux, das sind die Top-Level-Domains, die zählen.
Was wird ihm zur Last gelegt? Naja, im Prinzip, dass sie mit dem Share-Hoster
Mega Upload gleichzeitig ein Netzwerk betrieben haben,
dass dort auch ordentlich Raubkopien landen, damit Leute ordentlich bei Mega
Upload schnellere Downloads bezahlen.
Das ist im weitesten Sinne das, was ihm zur Last gelegt wird.
Die beiden Mitbegründer, Bram van der Kolk und Matthias Ortmann,
hatten schon im Sommer 2022 sich schuldig befunden und haben dann den Kim Dotcom schwer belastet.
Und jetzt in einem Deal mit der neuseeländischen und US-amerikanischen Justiz,
haben sie dann eingeräumt, dass sie zu einer organisierten Gruppe und einer
Verschwörung mit Dotcom zur Begehung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen beteiligt waren.
Haben dafür milde Strafen bekommen, weil sie jetzt den Dotcom kriegen wollen.
Jetzt haben die Anwälte es aber immer wieder geschafft, das Vorgehen der neuseeländischen
Sicherheitsbehörden irgendwie anzugreifen. Zum Beispiel.
Weil der Geheimdienst ihn überwacht hat, das war auf Wunsch der Polizei,
das ist in Deutschland verboten, in Neuseeland verboten, da musste sich der
Premierminister öffentlich bei dem entschuldigen, das hast du dein Land gut
in die Tonne geritten, wenn du dich am Ende bei so einem Vogel da entschuldigen musst.
Jedenfalls wurde jetzt geurteilt von einem neuseeländischen Auslieferungsrichter in diesem Verfahren,
der gesagt hat, naja, sieht so aus, als müsste der sich in den USA für diese
Vorwürfe verantworten. Ich werde den jetzt mal ausliefern.
Kim.com ist sich aber sehr sicher, dass das nicht passieren wird. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Sicherlich wird er das auch noch auf irgendeine Weise versuchen zu verhindern.
Vielleicht kriegen wir ein neues Musikvideo von ihm. Und dann ist mir noch eine
Sache, das müssen wir erwähnen, Tim.
Günther Oettinger ist Berater für Cybersicherheit, Datenschutz und Geopolitik.
Wirklich?
Ja, und zwar berät er da irgendwie ein Konzern mit dem Namen Shane oder Shein,
die irgendwie günstige Kleidung für Frauen wohl irgendwie verkaufen und sich
irgendwie in Europa Marktanteile haben wollen und sich da irgendwie Probleme haben,
weil sie so Sanktionen und Zölle in der Europäischen Union nicht so gerne haben möchten.
Und das heißt, dieser ehemalige EU-Kommissar engagiert sich jetzt für irgendein
asiatisches Billigware-Unternehmen, damit die nicht Sanktionen und Zölle der
Europäischen Union bekommen,
damit hier weiter irgendeine asiatische Billigware reingespielt wird und beruft sich dabei,
dass er, ich habe ein Mandat als freier Berater, eng begrenzt auf Cybersicherheit,
Datenschutz und Geopolitik.
Ich meine, das sagt der? Eng begrenzt. Das sagt der und dann wird der doch nicht mal rot bei.
Also erstmal eng begrenzt.
Als wäre ein Mandat als freier Berater eng begrenzt. Das ist einfach so eine Scheißformulierung.
Natürlich ist der als Berater einfach als Touröffner da.
Der ist ehemaliger EU-Kommissar. Der lässt sich da jetzt einfach noch von irgendwelchen
asiatischen Leuten, die ja ein bisschen was verkaufen wollen,
entsprechend als Touröffner bezahlen.
Und das Geile ist, dass er sogar sagt, dass das sehr wenig seiner Arbeitszeit in Anspruch nimmt.
Ja klar, natürlich, du sagst irgendwie dem einen mal so, wie hier der Philipp
Amthor auch, Augustus Intelligence, es ist ekelig, es ist ekelig.
Und dass der dann auch noch ohne rot zu werden behauptet, er wäre ein Berater für Cybersicherheit.
Das erkennt man ja schon daran, dass der Cybersicherheitsrat sagt,
dass er keine Ahnung vom Thema hat.
Also ich meine, das ist unglaublich.
Wie wärs denn mal mit Rente? 70 ist der Geht man da nicht in die Rente?
Oder hat der einfach noch nicht genug zusammen?
Also ich frage mich ja auch mal ein bisschen Was motiviert die Leute eigentlich
In dem hohen Alter noch Wenn du jetzt Ich glaube jetzt nicht,
dass er so Probleme hat Seinen Lebensabend zu finanzieren,
Ne Was soll denn dann der ganze Kram noch?
Ich glaube es Einfach geil fühlen
oder vielleicht auch einfach weiterhin irgendwo essen gehen zu können.
Einfach weiterhin ein Segment bei Logbuch-Netzpolitik sein.
Das machst du doch nur, um unsere Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen.
Alles für den Fame.
Das ist schlimm. So Leute, das war's. Schluss mit der 400er, mit dem 400er-Block.
Jetzt kommen die 500er-Status-Codes und die sind kurz. Schwierig.
Naja, problematisch. wenn man sie kriegt ärgerlich zu debuggen ja,
aber für euch, wir passen auf jetzt machen wir erstmal live wir treffen uns
in Berlin kommt alle und dann,
geht's weiter.
Wie immer wer weiß, vielleicht machen wir was völlig verrücktes.
Was wir noch nie gemacht haben who knows keine Ahnung okay, jetzt erstmal Schluss.
Bis bald, ciao ciao, tschüss.